Try My day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day,
which brings us to the fight that was pulled off this card.
Cain Velasquez versus Fabrizio for doom.
The rematch,
which everybody was looking forward to and a cane did that meeting with that uh,
that whatever a association.
Yes.
The Fighters Association and said that he's going to have to have a surgery
after this fight.
And they went,
what?
Why don't you step that he fucked up you.
They like,
you can't say you need a surgery before you have a major fight.
First of all that that's going to fuck with a betting lines.
There's a disaster there that's going to fuck with the insurance if something
happens to you.
And then afterwards they say,
Oh,
you know,
you,
you told us that you are already hurt.
We're not paying for this.
Like do you,
do you get paid,
um,
for like when you're in training camp and you get to a fight and you have to
pull out because the injury,
you don't get nothing.
Right.
What do you get?
Uh,
nothing.
Nothing.
So you got nothing.
So if he chose to fight with that injury,
he said he was going to be 100% he's going to have a cortisone injection and the
doctors disagreed.
The Nevada State Athletic Commission disagreed that,
uh,
Bob Bennett Guy,
he doesn't fucking playing the games man.
He's like,
you can't say something like that.
And then finally long to do that.
I fucked up.
He fucked up.
Just emotional when I called Linacre a little monkey earlier,
I fucked up.
See came fucked up.
You just talk,
you say things,
you know,
I was going to say,
well that's kind of racist,
but I call myself a monkey though.
I just,
it sounds,
it sounds worse than it really is.
It's not racist.
It's not race.
I'm the last person racist.
But the point is with when it comes to Cain is that it was a giant error and
that error pulled him off of this card and now he's going to have to fight.
He's going to have to get surgery and then he didn't have to fight.
Whoever the fuck has left and it's,
you're talking about more months out and then even more examination next time
and it's going to cost him a shit load of money.
A ton of money went through the entire camp.
He was a week out and they pull them from it.
And then he was saying,
I don't know what this is about.
I'm,
I'm 100% good to go.
I've been told I've been cleared.
So he was tweeting that he had been told that he was cleared right before they
pull them.
I thought you know I think you give the guy a physical examination in terms of
his movement.
Like what can you do?
Like,
how do you,
how do you tell the guy business wise,
business wise,
you can look in his bag back some since I added this why slide you kick cause
the UFC goes man,
you have a bulging disc,
you get the cortisone shot and then if you get punched in the face by her doing
where you get the guilty and you're paralyzed,
you sue the fuck out us cause we let your true business,
you just can't do that.
No deny.
I don't think it falls on.
Kay came knows better.
The people around this association shouldn't have let him do that.
Well first of all they should have known about first the Bjorn revenue thing is
very weird.
Like I was reading with John Fitch had written that John Fitch rather than an
interview said that he was very a disturbed by all this because there's a class
action lawsuit.
And what they're saying is that if the class action lawsuit is dropped like that
they could form this,
uh,
this union.
And if the all agreed to abandon the class action lawsuit,
it would,
it would like help the strength and form the union.
And John Fitch was like,
what?
Like,
so you're saying that the UFC would accept you as a union if you abandoned the
class action lawsuit that we've been chasing down for two years now without
picking any sides.
Like if you're on the side of the fighters,
not picking any sides,
you just have to look at that and go,
well what benefit would it be for the people that are not in this to accept that
the class action lawsuit has dropped?
This all sounds like someone's trying to get some money because there's no one's
doing this for free.
That's what everybody has to realize when it comes to like these agencies and
there's like three different competing ones that are stepping in,
right?
One soon.
The other,
there's the associate,
the two big ones.
There's association,
there's the Union.
Yeah.
Well ultimately I think we all want the same thing.
We all want fighters to be compensated fairly.
Want them to make a lot of money because it's a short window of time and it's an
awesome sport to watch,
right?
Correct.
So you got to wonder,
does this help that?
Does this help them?
Does it do any of these organizations?
They haven't yet.
Because if they can get together and organize and they're gonna fight right then
no one's gonna take you serious.
There's three different leaders,
three different ones,
and they all want different things.
And then you've got to wonder whose agenda's over here?
Whose agenda's over here?
What it has to come.
It can't come from businessman,
can't come from another promoter.
How's it come from the fighters,
the fighters,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
And I'm not saying current fighters because they need to fight and then they
need to have someone speak for them who's been there.
But you,
you can't have these business guys with other hidden agendas trying to get
things done.
Or,
or in a B,
orange case,
he has this,
you know,
weird jealousy with Dana and what's seem destroyed.
Well,
we can't have that.
Why are you speaking for us?
What are you doing?
Yeah,
you have,
you don't have the respect of the is what the fuck you're doing.
And notice he's taking a seat back because everyone,
when everyone saw him speaking,
they were like,
we're out,
man.
Yeah.
Well,
he was going old school bell tour when he was running things over there and a
king mo was pissed off at them and King Mo most of this day calls him a Dick
Rider all the time.
There's the whole,
it's not good when you've got a guy like king mo who's a very respected guy who
is horrible things to say about you.
And I talked the association,
I went,
what are you guys doing?
Like you have one way to make an impression and you do this.
You put your best foot forward with this guy and then,
well,
I don't know the dude.
Do you know him?
I know of fighters who have dealt with them.
I never thought for Bella tour.
So I know inside the fight or circle that people have dealt with him for manager
and stuff like that.
But also personally I was looking at all the tweets and all the negative stuff.
I think you can take a very positive angle about improving the life and the
conditions of these fighters without attacking people.
Yeah,
there's no,
there's no reason to attack.
It's also see what you want about Dana White.
It's not his job to make sure you guys get your shit together and form a
association.
He's like,
I'm a businessman.
I put on fights.
If you guys want to do that,
cool.
Get your shit together and then bring it to,
and then let's figure something out.
But if you guys are fighting with each other,
you don't want to Mcdonald's Gino
[inaudible].
Yeah.